what up everyone welcome to Chicago as
you can see behind me we got Lake
Michigan
we got the downtown skyline you know me
Allan saw Qian I'm here in the summer we
are crewing for tony robbins at his
unleash the power with an event passing
some time with some close family friends
doing some interviews you know thinking
a lot about time i'm excited to be
releasing that book and videos about
time very very soon i have some thoughts
about society that I want to share
thoughts on civilization thoughts about
society as we look around us we don't
even realize to the full extent what's
going on we're more so captivated by the
short term dopaminergic hijacks that are
going on we're not even aware of them as
in these little quickie short term
gratifying bursts of goodness that
happened in our head rather than
thinking in the long term so take for
take an example I was just at a fast
food restaurant like a week ago or
something like that and I posted this
video when I was just observing I
observed for like 10 minutes because I
just wanted to watch all of the
processes that were going on in the back
and I had this clear view to the back
there were like 10 employees a bunch of
them were flipping burgers putting
lettuce on a burger
there were people doing potatoes for
french fries there were people at the
cash register people packaging all of
this stuff wrapping it and I was just
thinking damn this is gonna be automated
and this is a lot of [ __ ] jobs and
we're not even preparing ourselves for
it it's the worst thing ever when
civilization is in the middle of
political gridlock between two very
you only get to talk about so little on
the political spectrum the red and the
blue and it's in gridlock and it's
barely progressing it is a little bit
barely and then you have this [ __ ]
monster force of AI and robotics that's
just [ __ ] about to take over the
entire economy and we're not even
talking about that as much when was the
last time that Congress made a full week
long Fiasco about AI in robotics and how
we needed to restructure our government
and civilization and society to be
prepared for the next five years in ten
years we're not we're not there's
already coffee and tea robots that are
inside of stores in San Francisco
there's already a burger machine that's
being developed in San Francisco that's
already ready to go and I'm putting put
into restaurant and this is just these
measly little retail things we already
see all these positions being automated
weird he know the list even doctors
aren't safe medical records scanning
medical diagnostics scanning we know
this whole list autonomous vehicles
trucks and taxicabs I mean we just look
around and we don't think twice we don't
we don't think twice about the millions
of jobs that are gonna be lost and
what's gonna replace them are we
retraining people for those replacement
jobs so it's become one of my missions
to help society realize what the [ __ ]
going on because if we don't we're in a
really shitty place we can't be so
trapped by the little tiny bit of
conversation that Fox News and CNN
enable us to have we got to expand our
awareness we got a enriched our minds to
new dimensions of thought and
consciousness that are going to enable
us to have the foresight to see AI and
robotics and the fact that that's gonna
have on us we gotta be prepared we have
to
be prepared otherwise we're gonna
experience some major suffering some
huge economic and political turmoil
across the world and I am NOT okay with
that
I want to bring this force I in enrich
more people I know a lot of people are
thinking about it this is just one of
many things that I've learned that I
have a good amount of foresight about
another thing that I think I have a good
amount of foresight about is what's
going on with blockchain and
cryptocurrency there's a whole
revolution whatever is gonna happen to
fiat currency or paper money that has
been enabling us to exchange these
sheets of paper for services and goods
which has been fantastic it's enabled us
to achieve so much with our economy and
progressing civilization moving forward
and it's been thanks to the centralized
banking system that we believe has been
implemented by the Rothschilds in all
these countries and then circulate that
money that enables people to do all
these different things the people work
for they earn and they go spend but this
is about to be flipped on its head who
knows maybe Satoshi Nakamoto was maybe
that was a Rothschild maybe maybe maybe
they're the ones that eked out
cryptocurrency because they knew would
be inevitable blockchains so we never
know we'll never know maybe we'll know
later who knows but right now it's it's
it's a major transition into that field
and we have no idea where that's gonna
take us none none we don't know how fiat
currencies gonna die and how stabili its
gonna die without suffering or major
issues and how cryptocurrency is gonna
rank up above all else and how that is
gonna affect things like wealth
inequality how that's gonna affect
things like maybe the way that people of
lower socioeconomic status can now
become investors which is very
interesting there's not so many
regulations that only the rich can
invest so this is all very very
interesting and that's having a major
play here
so as biotechnology we're now sequencing
the every letter of our own genomes as
well as understanding the code of life
just in general and what is that
enabling us to do like eradicate disease
we can now design children that are
being born into the world to have
specific traits that we want and China
doesn't have regulations on this so
they're going full-fledged full-speed
moving forward recently I heard they
were taking the eggs from women of the
same woman and impregnating them with
the sperm of the same man and then
letting it populate - about 16 cells and
then taking those cells one cell from
each of these different babies that was
slowly being born and that they would
sequence it and the one that had about
40 or so genes they think are the ones
that signal intelligence they found the
one with the greatest signal for
intelligence and they threw away the
rest of the 16 these little 16 group
cells the rest of those kids and could
let the one continue growing that was
most intelligent and this is very
interesting because we are moving into a
new era of humanity a new era of
civilization and we're not talking about
this when was the last time that
Congress had a conversation about
genetic engineering and the impact that
it's gonna have on civilization why are
we not talking about these things it's
very frustrating and there's so much
more neuro tech plugging brain computer
interfaces
I am so concerned about where we're
going with that because it just gives
people a direct plug into the mind yeah
it'd be great to just think thoughts and
send messages and phone calls and and
get Wikipedia directly and downloaded
into my brain and all this good stuff
but also make some controlling people
very easy we just need to have better
foresight we need to look at
civilization and we need to look at
exponential technology and we need to
realize where things are going and make
the proper moves today to prevent mass
of suffering an issue moving forward
come on let's get our [ __ ] together so
it's great seeing Africa eradicate a lot
of suffering gain a lot of more
progressive principles and capitalistic
principles and enable them to skyrocket
and jump forward that's been great to
see that happen and it seems like the
world is slowly globalizing and
realizing how to work together we sure
do hope so The Rock's very small we got
to figure out how to work together on
this rock only takes 40 days to sail
around the whole rock thanks everyone
for tuning in about these thoughts on
civilization and these thoughts on
society hope you guys had a good time if
you learned something new pass it along
to two people have them pass along to
two people let's get more conversation
going like this much love everyone
greatly appreciate you tuning in join us
on simulation series on YouTube and on
patreon we'd love to continue having
your support bless Chicago and bless
Lake Michigan this is a really beautiful
place and thanks everyone for watching
much love
you